[Music]
straight ahead
all on crime daily a record settlement
in the police shooting of brianna taylor
and is the largest
amount ever paid out for a black woman
in a wrongful death killed by a police
in america plus we need to know what
happened to our father
the daughters of carol baskin's late
husband don lewis
stole the show last night on dancing
with the stars
and i said the last time i was back in
the corner
my daughter disappeared he's back in the
corner again he could kill these
children
social services workers failed to heed
those warnings and now two children
are dead their mother presumed murdered
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and thanks for joining us on law and
crime daily i'm erin keller along with
terry austin and brian buckmeyer
we begin in kentucky where the city of
louisville will pay briana taylor's
family 12 million dollars to settle a
wrongful death lawsuit
police shot and killed taylor when
plainclothes officers executed a
no-knock warrant at her home
gunfire erupted when taylor's new
boyfriend said she mistook
the police for intruders taylor's mother
said today's settlement
was only a partial victory as
significant as today
is it's only the beginning of getting
full justice for brianna
we must not lose focus on what the real
job is
and with that being said it's time to
move forward
with the criminal charges because she
deserves that
and much more
her beautiful spirit and personality
is working through all of us on the
ground so please
continue to say her name
brianna thailand the mayor of louisville
said the settlement requires police
reforms
we will now require a commanding officer
to review and approve
all search warrants affidavits in
support of search warrants
and risk matrices before an officer
seeks judicial approval for the warrant
we're cr we're creating a clear command
structure when executing warrants
at multiple locations we're adding
additional protocols for money seized
as evidence expanding the random drug
testing of officers
and we will negotiate with the fop in
2021
to expand on the records that can be
maintained in an officer's
personnel files still an attorney for
briana taylor's family says
advocacy cannot stop with this
settlement
we are not going to stop our calls to
hold the officers
responsible for brianna's death
accountable we're going to continue to
put pressure on the attorney general's
office
to present a fair case to the grand jury
and we're going to wait
we know that that indictment is coming
from the grand jury we have faith that
an indictment is coming from the grand
jury
in addition to the attorney general's
office we must remember that the fbi
is also doing an investigation into
whether there are criminal civil rights
violations leading to
and after briana taylor's death so we're
going to be looking for for the federal
indictment to come from the department
of justice as well
brian buckmeyer and terry austin now for
analysis so terry
taylor's family says this settlement
basically wraps up their lawsuit against
all of the officers this sounds like
this closes the door
on the civil case completely well yes
it does close the door as far as damages
are concerned but the settlement went
beyond the monetary payment aaron it
also included police reform like you
heard like requiring the officers
to volunteer and underserved communities
and it also
is requiring commanding officers to
approve
all search warrants so that's going to
avoid the type of situation we had here
and terry is it rare to actually get a
dollar amount in a settlement sometimes
those are confidential
well you know if the parties agree that
they can talk about the amount yes you
can go ahead and do that it's only if
you say that the terms and conditions of
the settlement
are supposed to be confidential so here
obviously they agreed they could talk
about the amount
and some states require those amounts to
be open in open records laws and whatnot
so brian does this
impact the attorney general's
investigation and the criminal case and
how
i i guess it's it's it's twofold in one
aspect you're thinking about right now
the temperature of louisville i think
this might help suicide that
because it is a 12 million dollar reward
if you're thinking about in terms of
context eric garner's family got 5.9
million dollars after he was
killed so it is a large amount by many
standards but people are still going to
now turn
all of their attention to say hey if the
city's willing to give a 12 million what
about the criminal case
let's turn to another case now the mayor
of rochester new york has fired his
city's police chief over the
controversial
in-custody death of daniel prude
shocking body camera footage shows
officers putting a hood on prude's head
and shoving his face into the ground
while he was naked and handcuffed
the police chief and his command staff
announced their retirement after this
video became public
but the mayor now says the chief is
fired two weeks
before he was scheduled to step down the
mayor is also calling for a federal
investigation
and police reforms in that city the
tiger king star known for her big cat
rescue project made her debut on abc's
dancing with the stars
carol baskin danced the night away to
the tune of eye of the tiger but
during the show the family of baskin's
former husband had a surprise of their
own
don lewis was reported missing in 1997
he's presumed dead
and his family speculates baskin may
have been involved
i'm linda one of don lewis's daughters
and we miss
our dad i'm donna i'm don lewis's oldest
daughter
we need to know what happened to our
father
i'm anne don's former assistants
all we're asking is justice for don
don lewis mysteriously disappeared in
1997. his family deserves answers
they deserve justice do you know who did
this or if carol baskin was involved
a hundred thousand dollar reward has
been funded
that's an incredible ad in the middle of
that broadcast attorney john phillips
told law and crime the purpose of that
ad was simple
we knew carol baskin was going to have
essentially a captive nation
during dancing with the stars and get to
tell her narrative
in full as as she wanted to tell it
the problem is she's had that narrative
for 23 years
and the family hasn't the scales of
justice
can balance if both sides get to talk
the fact is everybody's talking about
don lewis today
along with how bad of a dancer she was
but everybody's talking about don lewis
today and if we hadn't
aired the ad it'd have been just a
forgotten part of the story
right brian buckmeyer he's throwing
shade there about the dancing he's
taking out the ad in the middle of the
broadcast
i mean how many different ways could he
jab at carol baskin
i mean this was a boxing match he went
from left hook to right hook to haymaker
i mean the video is about controlling
the narrative and i think they won
that uh because yes her dancing was not
the greatest
and definitely changed the narrative
everybody's piling on carol baskin here
let's talk about the lawsuit there's a
civil case going on between
the daughters and carol baskin terry do
they have a chance of getting a judge to
even hear it because it's been filed
more than two decades after lewis
disappeared
well you know erin while carol is
dancing with the stars the daughters are
taking on
a very serious business they filed a
lawsuit and it wasn't
actually for damages it's what's called
a bill of discovery they just want to
find out
more information about their father and
his will presumably
that information could lead to a lawsuit
but baskin's already claiming that any
alleged claim
would be time barred so interesting
there that they're basically just trying
to dig into this a little bit more
that's exactly right she's actually
saying carol is the fact that they're
just doing a fishing expedition
and along it moves through the courts
and still ahead on law and crime daily
sentencing for a man who admits he
played a role in the murder
of a tennessee 20 year old and later on
a husband suspected of killing his wife
goes on to kill his children and then
himself
their family explains the warning signs
they say the authorities refused to
listen to
and out of a sentencing caring for a
defendant who admitted his role in the
killing of a young tennessee woman
nearly a decade ago holly bobo
disappeared from her family back in 2011
hunters discovered some of her remains
three years later
john dylan adams pleaded guilty but
co-defendant jason autry testified
against
zach adams at trial
what are your expectations
you know what i mean by that for
testifying here today
what do you think's gonna happen i'm
hoping for leniency
he asked me would i help him bury the
body
and i said yeah i said i will i brought
the upper torso
to the end of the tailgate where he
grabbed the legs
and i set the head the upper end on the
rip-rap pile
i told him i said he's still alive out
of the floorboard of pickup
he pulls a pistol i looked around and i
told him
there was nothing coming close it's
clear something to that
to that effect and at that time
boom the gun sounded gun went out
and it sounded like boom boom boom
underneath that bridge was just one shot
but it echoed underneath that bridge
all the way down that damn river bottom
autry's plea deal was for an eight-year
sentence he's been in jail for that long
so with credit for time served he'll
basically be a free man his testimony
was some of the most credible persuasive
testimony i've ever heard given in a
courtroom
plead guilty to facilitating especially
aggravated kidnapping
that's a an amended charge being an
eight year sentence as a range one
standard defender
thirty percent classification count two
you'd be pleading guilty to solicitation
murder one
receive an eight year sentence range one
standard defender
and uh thirty percent classification
they will run concurrent do you
understand what that means
yes sir they're also running concurrent
with the federal senate
yeah sure let's talk about the procedure
of this case brian
audrey testifies with hopes of leniency
he did not have a plea deal
at all when he took the stand a few
years back the defense said there was no
deal whatsoever until
30 days ago and the judge said the other
co-defendants would have been entitled
to the same deal
if they had been if audrey had been
given one
for testifying in the original trial
does this make sense to you
so taking it all on face value and not
knowing anything more would probably
happen as one defense attorney said hey
you might not put a physical deal on the
table but my client has something good
to say
and let's see and hope if that rings
true and gets him a good deal so i think
this was
a bit of a hail mary toss-up by the
defense attorney and thankfully someone
caught it in the end zone
this happens differently in different
jurisdictions terry in some
jurisdictions and correct me if i'm
wrong defendants won't flip unless they
have a deal on the record right
well that is right aaron and the
incentive to flip and testify against
another defendant is
really based on the offer to either
lower the charge or
not serve any jail time and on the one
hand you know the deal helps you to
convict
the other defendants but it brings
closure to the case
together exactly all three defendants
have now been tried or their cases
adjudicated
and when we return the grandparents of
two murdered children
open up to law and crime daily about the
abusive father and husband
who killed those he claimed to love the
state's failure in that case led to a 98
million dollar verdict
that's when we return
[Music]
and now tomorrow from my recent
conversation with the parents of a young
mother presumed murdered
by her own husband susan powell
disappeared in december 2009
her husband josh claimed he took their
children on a midnight
camping trip in sub-zero temperatures
when susan disappeared
he went on to maintain his innocence in
her presumed killing
in 2012 josh locked a social services
worker out of his home during a
supervised visit
killed his children with a hatchet and
killed himself by setting the house on
fire
susan's parents charles and judy cox say
they believe josh
killed susan by offering her poisoned
pancakes to eat
they described for us the breakdown of
the relationship
and their troubling search for answers
we saw
red flags we felt he was very
uh domineering or spoke so much
i think a good way to describe it is we
saw the tip of the iceberg
and we had no idea how much more iceberg
there was underwater
uh beyond our vision we had no idea we
were dealing with such a problem
and i know our daughter didn't have an
idea of that either
so susan disappears and then that leaves
joshua and the children what do you
think happened to your daughter
i'm convinced that the the pancake
episode
stuff was poisoning of sue of susan
and that he did something dump the body
somewhere at the time i thought well
maybe she took off
because we had a safety plan that she
was going to take off
to protect herself and then i would get
down there and she would get in
touch with me and we could get our
attorneys involved and we could
battle to get her children back and
things like that get the children back
and
uh but that she never contacted me
and so i and then i learned later that
he had her cell phone
and so i i realized that yeah she
whatever happened that night he got rid
of her
and uh he's kept he was adamant that
well i did
i wouldn't kill her i didn't i don't
know which uh
you know i don't believe for a minute
but
i know that had he not drugged her
or poisoned her that she didn't realize
the danger that she was getting herself
into clearly
within three or four days of her missing
they felt it was a homicide and then
ultimately we wind up in the situation
where joshua winds up
with the children alone and it just does
the most unspeakable thing possible yeah
josh
got had control of the children and i
understood that from the beginning
he is the surviving parent he's the one
person who's there for the children
uh then but when he moved out from his
uh house there in utah
it was clear to me that he knew she
wasn't coming back that's where in place
susan did not want
those children and when they were there
being grandparents with no rights to do
say anything or do anything really no
recognized rights
then that's uh that's
the situation we were in and we just
continued on hoping that uh
the police would find susan or find
evidence that they could use to arrest
josh so ultimately all of your hopes
were
attached to the police investigation
hoping that that would put a stop to
josh because you didn't have the
independent right to jump in
and get involved in the situation
yourselves it must have been extremely
frustrating
josh had all the uh advantage into being
a the only parent could speak and he
could speak for susan as her her husband
except for he was speaking against susan
as her husband so we took on the role of
defending our daughter
and correcting the things the lies and
the
the statements that josh and his family
made against our daughter
and that left the cox's in a legal
nightmare one which ended with a
multi-million dollar civil verdict
handed down recently when we come back
what charles and judy cox think happened
to their daughter and
what motive they say their son-in-law
had to kill
his own children
[Music]
the grandparents of braden and charlie
powell believe the boy's father became
increasingly worried when the boy
started to remember
events surrounding their mother's death
likely
at their father's own hands that left
joff powell
fearful the cox's say that the children
may potentially have been on a path to
speak out against him
they were just really trusting us
and talking to us and then they started
to
say things that were kind of disturbing
and they were starting to remember
things
and that really scared josh and
he wanted of course for them to be taken
away from
us and put with anyone he
said i don't care who it is but just not
the coxas because
they're dangerous people there was one
time charlie said to me around christmas
time
just before they went were killed anyway
he said here's a he
had drawn me a picture of a wreath and
it had
a picture of his mom in the middle and
said help us find her
and he wanted me to get that to the
media
so that maybe somebody would start
looking for his mother he finally
figured
that out that he would like to other
people to help look for his mother
and uh i just remember
feeling oh my gosh i hope you don't say
this to your father
because that would just set him off
terribly
you know that here is his son now wants
to know where his mother is and was
turning to
the media which he'd been taught as
terrible and
turning to me to do that and we are
convinced or i'm convinced anyway i
should say
that charlie and braden know what
happened to their mother
much more than they were allowed to say
and the older they're
getting the more they have words to
describe
what they than their tonight terrors or
their
dreams about what really happened to
things that they know
and so i think josh was afraid of that
and he knew his time was about
he was backed into a corner and the last
time he was backed in the corner by
susan
either straighten up or i'm filing for
divorce
she goes missing and we haven't heard
from her again
the state's decision to put the children
back together with their father turned
fatal of course and resulted
in the cox's receiving a 98 million
dollar victory against the state
terry and brian let's jump in with some
discussion here to wrap
wrap up the show i should say a huge
verdict one that sends a message terry
the civil trial though was a mess with
social workers
basically uh saying that our procedures
say one thing they're testifying to
another thing
the cox's say that the social workers
were lying sanitizing reports
it was just a mess from my understanding
it sounds like a mess aaron and i think
the jury made the right decision here
there's no question if the department
was
not following their own policies and
procedures and they were ignoring the
pleas of these poor grandparents
then they came down with the right
decision and they
said that in fact the department of
children services was liable
hopefully aaron this 98 million verdict
is going to make a difference
and be a wake-up call for the department
and that exactly is what the cox's hope
they're saying they want to use the
money for advocacy
so brian this was a pretty straight out
negligence case they won because the
state breached a duty of care
to look after the children i got to ask
this question though
when you listen to the grandparents
speak it sounds like they would have
been
excellent witnesses had the father
survived and they needed to testify as
to
premeditation and a reason why he would
have wanted to do this
what i heard was a very well thought out
reasonable motive as to why this father
would have wanted to silence his
children
as they said as children grow they start
to gain the vocabulary to describe
instances that they might not have
when they were younger and i think that
would have been very fearful if these
facts were true and very damaging if it
went to trial
so many what ifs but we won't have that
trial thanks a lot brian terry for great
analysis today here on law and crime
daily and thank you so much for joining
us
we'll see you back here tomorrow with
america's hottest real-life
court battles
[Music]
you